- [Kelly] Have y'all, have y'all met?
- No, I've never met her.
- Never, never.
- I was gonna say, that
hug meant yes. Yes.
Okay, so wait. Jurnee,
one of your first movies
was Eve's Bayou, which turns 25 this year.
That's incredible.
How do you feel things have progressed
for black women in film,
in front of the camera
and behind?
Because you're working in both.
Look at you both.
You both, they both looked over.
- You know-
- Yeah, yeah!
- You want me to take it?
- Oh my God, you,
you don't really wanna
answer the question.
- I think the truth of
the matter is, is like,
I'm encouraged because
there's so many more of us
behind the camera,
executive producing, producing, writing
directing, ushering forward
stories that aren't typically,
you know, pushed forward by
the cis white male, right?
- Yeah.
- You know, and so I'm excited
because there's so many
voices to be excited about.
How are we, we have so
far to go, you know.
- So far. So far.
- Yeah.
- We're like step one on like a thousand,
but we're getting there,
we're getting there.
And there's a lot of people who are part
of the solution and creating
the change we wanna be.
And we all have production companies
and we're all just trying
to, you know, employ more,
you know, amazing, talented
people who have been underserved
in our community.
- Yeah, and I think so many
people are just not waiting
for an invitation to sit at the table.
They're just like, "We're
gonna build our own table."
- We built our own table in
our own house on our own land.
Yeah.
- Amen.
- Yeah, I love, it's
interesting topic in general,
just for women as well,
because I literally just did this thing
with Dolly who just
re-released "Nine to Five",
and it's interesting 'cause
there's a whole documentary
about it, how it's still
applicable, you know,
the message is still applicable.
And it was so many years ago.
I wanna get to a place
where we don't have to have
the conversation, you know,
that would be beautiful.
- So people don't lose
it over a black mermaid.
- Yeah. Someone lost it
over a black mermaid?
- A lot of people. They're
like, "She's black!"
I'm like, "She's a fish."
(audience laughing)
- She's a fish,
but also she's a-
- Oh my God, you were-
- Her friend is a talking crab.
The authenticity thing is...
- I didn't know this.
But wait, like, mermaids aren't real.
- They're not real.
Fish don't talk.
- Like, how dare you?
How dare you suppose?
- Middle earth isn't
real either. People have
very strong feelings.
- Middle earth isn't real.
Oh wow. But the new movie is called "Lou",
and the weather kind of plays
a character in it, right?
- Oh yeah, absolutely. The
entire film takes place
in a storm.
- How fun was that filming?
- Ugh, define fun.
No, I mean, honestly, I'm
that weird person that's like,
"Oh it's raining and we're
in mud and blood and sweat?
Yeah, this is my kind of movie."
But, honestly, you're
just wet the whole time,
and you're just uncomfortable,
and you're muddy,
and you know, so it was,
like, really disgusting,
but it was fun.
- [Kelly] You went really method.
- Yeah.
- Swamp butt is fun.
That's what it is. Swamp butt.
- Was it cool to work with Allison Janney?
- Oh, she's such an icon.
She's such a legend.
And, honestly, my favorite
part about working
with her is just watching her do something
that she's never done before.
I mean, she went full on
action star in this movie
and at 61 years old.
- Yeah.
- She's wearing this long,
beautiful silver hair,
and she is kicking butt
in this movie.
And I just, I'm so excited
for people to see that
representation.
- It's kind of a different
role for her, too.
- It's a different role for her,
but we also don't get to see
mature women of that age.
- Yeah, Amen.
- You know, kicking butt,
but they can kick butt, too.
- Yeah, no, I like, I like
that. I love that, too.
So, so tell everybody
what the movie's about,
other than being in a storm.
It looks like your kid's been taken.
- Yeah, so my kid is kidnapped
and I enlist the help of my neighbor
who's kind of this grumpy
woman who doesn't like me.
And we have to go on this rescue mission
to get my child back in
the middle of this storm
in the middle of the night.
But we are forced to work together.
We're two women who don't like each other,
come from very different backgrounds,
and through this rescue
mission are forced to
kind of gain a deeper
understanding and respect
for each other.
- That is my worst nightmare.
That's every parent's worst nightmare
is your kid getting taken.
- Are you kidding me?
- Like, is that hard to go
into those roles that, like,
if that happened in real
life, that's devastating.
Is that hard?
- You know, yeah.
- To like pop out of?
- The thing is it's a very dark
place to go to as an actor.
- Yeah.
- But I don't know for me,
I feel like you gotta sacrifice
something at the altar,
you know, like I prefer
to take on these roles
that are challenging, that do push me,
that do force me to go to
those really uncomfortable,
uncomfortable parts of my mind.
You know, but, but this
film is very empowering
- As well.
- Yeah.
And so it was a lot about tapping
into that mama bear strength, right,
that primal part of our
brains where it's like
if you mess with my
child, I'm coming for you.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And so for me, the, it wasn't
about living in the darkness.
It was actually about living in that
power and that strength of being a mother.
- Another optimist, look at that. Okay.